et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
vendrez la noce bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
réalisateur et vous êtes venu nous
parler ce matin du travail qui vous a
occupé pendant une dizaine d'années ça
n'est pas rien une enquête titanesque
sur la face cachée du bouddhisme il
s'agit d'un livre qui vient de sortir
chez jean claude lattès et d'un
documentaire qui est à voir sur arte
intitulé tous les deux bouddhisme la loi
du silence une enquête sur les travers
d'une religion qui en occident et dans
la conscience populaire au dessus de
tout soupçon le bouddhisme donc ou
plutôt la branche tibétaine du
bouddhisme qui est minoritaire dans le
bouddhisme mais qui est bien connu ici
notamment grâce à son chef spirituel
détenteur du prix nobel de la paix le
dalaï lama quel a été le point de départ
de votre travail au départ c'est ma
consoeur elodie emery qui avec qui j'ai
rédigé ce livre est fait le fait le film
qui avait pas mal enquêter sur une
organisation qui s'appelle rick bakas
l'organisation d'un lama sur gallery
coach et ses galeries paul chez pendant
longtemps il est considéré comme le
numéro deux du bouddhisme tibétain il
est moins connu du grand public que le
dalaï lama mais vraiment il tutoie le
dalaï lama et les treks très connu dans
les cercles bouddhistes tibétains et
elodie avait enquêté sur cette
organisation suite à un témoignage
qu'elle avait reçu d'une jeune femme qui
lui avait raconté avoir passé plusieurs
années aux côtés du la masse égale
rinpoche a vraiment en charge des tâches
les plus ingrates
vraiment au quotidien je dirais c'est à
dire que elle s'occupait de le laver
vraiment de toutes ces tâches et
notamment lui a confié avoir été par
moment son esclave sexuelle en quelque
sorte on appelle ça une taquiner c'est à
dire qu'en droit elle était à côté au
quotidien du maître et elle devait
vraiment répondre au moindre de ses
besoins ce témoignage là évidemment
profondément marqué elle a commencé à
enquêter sur cette organisation sur ce
gourou ce galerie coacher et au fur et à
mesure elle s'est rendu compte que
y'avait pas qu'un témoignage dans une
organisation y en avait plusieurs et
c'est à ce moment là qu'on a commencé à
enquêter ensemble on s'est rendu compte
que dans plusieurs organisations
bouddhiste tibétaine en europe on a
commencé par l'europe on s'est rendu
compte qu'on avait des victimes qui
racontait à peu près les mêmes
témoignages le fait qu'elle avait été
disons réduite presque en esclavage et
qu'il y avait aussi des histoires d'abus
sexuels voilà il est question dans votre
enquête d'abus sexuel y compris sur des
mineurs d'abus psychologique de
maltraitance mais aussi de malversations
financières de la part de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler l'équivalent des
prêtres peut-être dans le bouddhisme des
lamas qui sont tous plus ou moins adoubé
par le dalaï lama ça alors en réalité un
lavage c'est vrai que dans notre
conception un peu
ce qu'on connaît la chrétienté c'est un
peu difficile de trouver des équivalents
en gros un lama c'est une sorte de guide
spirituel c'est un référent et en tant
qu'adepte on va d'une certaine manière
prendre des voeux c'est à dire qu'on va
choisir un lama et une fois qu'on a
choisi son la main on a une espèce de
relation il ya un bon voilà c'est la
dévotion sait rien qui s'appelle le
samaya c'est effectivement une sorte de
dévotion qui vous lie à votre lama et
donc cela m'a il est censé vous guider à
peu près
partout je dirais le long d'un chemin
qui est le chemin de l'éveil donc on est
censé atteindre les vagues et
finalement il ya une sorte de
de confiance qui est censé se crée entre
le
l'étudiant je dirais le dicible et son
lama sauf que par moment les chemins
empruntés sont extrêmement dangereux et
ça on a beaucoup d'experts et
spécialistes du bouddhisme du bouddhisme
tibétain qui nous l'ont raconté
effectivement pour guider le disciple
vers l'éveil par moments le lama usent
de techniques qui peuvent vous
déstabiliser dans le but un peu de de
dissoudre votre égo en tout cas c'est
comme ça que ça nous a été rapporté et
finalement cette relation de dévotion de
confiance en un guide spirituel qui est
à peu près autorisé à tout pour vous
amener sur le chemin de l'éveil par
moments c'est utilisé pour la créer des
situations d'emprise qui peuvent mener
jusqu'à des abus sexuels à vous avez
rencontré plusieurs dizaines de victimes
dont on le disait certaines ont été
abusés enfants qui raconte tout les
mêmes mécanismes amaigri sont les mêmes
mécanismes malheureusement dans tous les
scandales sexuels qu'on retrouve
effectivement celle de l'emprise celle
du secret est ce que vous décrivez
raconté dans votre enquête c'est que il
ya eu un comme un système quoi qui a
permis de protéger ou de couvrir tous et
tous ces guides spirituels oui
effectivement en fait le travail qu'on a
qu'on a essayé de faire avec avec elodie
emery c'est que on s'est rendu compte
non seulement que ces témoignages se
ressembler c'est pour ça que on parle
parfois d'un système c'est à dire un
système à la fois au niveau des victimes
qu'il s'agit pas d'une victime d'un
centre mais vraiment on en a trouvé dans
beaucoup de centres où on a enquêté mais
en plus de ça quand on s'est rendu
compte que du coup il y avait un certain
nombre de centres et de victimes on
s'est un peu interrogé sur qui avait
essayé de tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
pour le dire un peu simplement et on
s'est rendu compte que beaucoup de ces
victimes avaient parlé soit dans leurs
propres communautés soient avait même
écrit à dharamsala dharamsala c'est la
ville dans le nord de l'inde où habite
aujourd'hui le dalaï lama où il est
réfugié depuis qu'il est parti du tibet
la la fin des années 50 et est en fait
ces alertes ont été donnés à différents
moments et on raconte nous dans le
documentaire on s'est rendu compte que
ces alertes elle avait été portée devant
le dalaï lama au début des années 90 on
a même retrouvé une archive assez
exclusive en tout cas il n'est dit
hassan est assez incroyable il ya
effectivement des des guides venus
d'europe qui disent au dalaï lama il
faut que vous disiez publiquement qu'il
y à ces abus lui fini par botté en
touche et le dira finalement il dit rien
la scène effectivement la wii la scène
est assez improbable en tout cas nous on
nous l'avait rapporté on connaissait
l'existence de ceux de ce moment je
dirais mais le fait de l'avoir
évidemment filmé au début des années 90
à dharamsala c'était assez incroyable et
donc c'est maître tibétain occidentaux
sont allés voir le dalaï lama et lui ont
dit effectivement que pendant des années
ils avaient reçu des lettres le dalaï
lama d'ailleurs qu'on reconnaîtra
lui-même avoir reçu des alertes de la
part de victimes occidentales de l'ama
bouddhistes tibétains pour autant au
moment où cette communication ce
communiqué est censé être rédigée par
tous les participants le dalaï lama doit
apporter sa signature sur le document ce
qui vous donnera une certaine force et
effectivement il le leur nom sera à
signer ce document et du coup c'est
cette communication n'aura finalement
pas d'effet alors certains de ces guides
spirituels incriminés ont fait l'objet
de procédures judiciaires c'est le ghana
le cas notamment de quelqu'un qui
s'appelle robert comme ce patch qui a
été condamné à plusieurs années de
prison d'autres sont encore en activité
après ses jeux sur bears parce que la
justice belge est en fête et s'est
pourvu en cassation manqué pour
l'instant toujours présumé innocent
voila voila merci pour cette précision
vous parliez tout à l'heure du lama
sodial rimpoché qui lui est mort sans
avoir véritablement répondu à ces actes
on parlait donc du dalaï lama qui qui
n'a donc qui assume mais rien dit là
encore ça rappelle quand même d'autres
scandales sexuels dans d'autres
religions et puis dans ce documentaire
vous écornée également la réputation
d'un des moines bouddhistes français les
plus connus qui s'appelle mathieu ricard
qu'est le traducteur du dalaï lama qui
l'une des voix les plus connus on ici en
occident vous dit que lui aussi a été
mis au courant de plusieurs affaires
d'abus que lui non plus n'a rien dit il
a réagi après la diffusion de votre
documentaire que vous at il dit
alors il déjà nous on a eu l'opportunité
de leur offre oui on l'a on la rencontre
et on a pu faire une interview avec lui
une interview dans laquelle finalement
matthieu ricard raconte qu' il ne
pouvait pas savoir est que en gros il
estime que ce n'est pas son rôle c'est
pas son rôle lui il se considère
uniquement comme le traducteur du dalaï
lama et il estime que finalement le
poids médiatique qu'il a acquis au fur
et à mesure des années il est
effectivement comme vous le rappeliez
extrêmement connue en france et en
europe il est invité en permanence sur
les plateaux de télévision à la radio
mais ils estiment que ce poids
médiatique finalement ne le en doute la
responsabilité ne lui incombe pas
finalement après l'entretien
si c'est plutôt pas trop mal passé il a
préféré de nous envoyer un courrier
d'avocat en demandant que l'interview ne
soient pas utilisés dans le film
elle est quand même raconté dans le
livre on raconte un peu c'est les
détails de ce qui s'est passé et
aujourd'hui on voit que matthieu ricard
finalement qualifie notre travail de
salutaire effectivement quand on voit
l'ampleur de l'enquète et le nombre de
témoignages je pense qu'on peut pas il
ne peut pas vraiment dire autre chose et
il estime finalement que aujourd'hui il
reconnaît que son importance médiatique
finalement le pousse à réagir et eddy
peut-être que je me suis pas rendu
compte de cela moi j'ai pas vraiment
d'avis sur la question jeu on a compilé
des témoignages on s'est rendu compte
qu'ils avaient beaucoup de personnes qui
s'étaient adressés à matthieu ricard
notamment parce qu'il s'est affichée
auprès de ses maîtres pendant des années
et qu'il n'avait jamais condamné
publiquement c'est à dire que le
problème dans le bouddhisme tibétain
c'est que
les mettre entre eux n'ont pas le droit
c'est à dire que ce serait aussi faire
une énorme faute ils n'ont pas le droit
de se condamner les uns les autres donc
matthieu ricard s'était limité à
expliquer publiquement dans des
courriers en la définition d'un lama
authentique mais c'est parce que
demandaient les victimes les victimes
elles ont été abusée pendant 20 ans elle
disait pas besoin qu'on me dise qui est
authentique à ce qu'il paraît
authentique et il voulait voler une
prise de position de matthieu ricard ce
qu'il a vraiment tardé à faire il semble
le faire maintenant je pense qu'on peut
s'en féliciter voilà il se défend aussi
en disant qu'il n'y a pas d'autorité
centrale dans le bouddhisme tibétain ce
sont ses mots à ce que vous diriez que
ces guides spirituels incriminés ont pu
compter sur la réputation qu'on peut
qu'on partage sans doute ici d'ailleurs
d'une religion de paix d'amour
d'être de son prochain qui paraît a
priori rien vous invitez qui dit dans
documentaire un moment épargné de la
saleté du monde quoi et que ça ils ont
pu du terreau d'une façon miser là
dessus en disant que ça ne sortira
jamais oui alors en fait moi je pense
que
si vous vouliez a une responsabilité
sans doute de l'institution bouddhiste
tibétaine de ne pas avoir su comment
parler à ses victimes comme on les
accompagne et c'est en tout cas ce qu
elles nous ont rapporté 1 depuis plus de
trente ans après ce qui est intéressant
dans le travail qu'on a mené c'est qu'on
s'est rendu compte aussi que on avait
aussi sans doute de notre côté pas
forcément voulu voir il ya eu toute une
construction on n'aurait pas le temps là
mais on pour revenir aux jésuites où l
exploratrice alexandra david néel qui
est sans doute connu de certains de vos
téléspectateurs qui sont des gens qui
ont vraiment diffuser une image
particulière du bouddhisme tibétain
qui serait une religion sans dieu après
il ya des années 70 finalement c'est
devenu aussi une espèce de deux modes de
vie alternatifs pour des gens qui
cherchaient quelque chose d'un peu
différent du modèle occidental que et et
finalement la politique aussi que porte
au dalaï lama effectivement le rôle
politique du dalaï lama était très
important donc le finalement le tibet et
le dalaï lama ont réussi à incarner une
sorte d'eldorado spirituel qu'on a été
aussi nous occidentaux est extrêmement
réticent à égratigner et c'est ce qu'on
sait ce dont on s'est rendu compte c'est
à dire qu'en fait ces histoires elle
était quand même connu à l'intérêt du
bouddhisme tibétain mais elle n'avait
jamais eu d'écho à l'extérieur en
quelques mots vous pensez qu'il y aura
d'autres victimes qui parleront après là
diffusion notamment de votre enquête en
très rapidement oui parce que on a déjà
de nouveaux témoignages qui nous arrive
je pense que ce travail comme l'a dit
mathieu ricard un peu ironiquement mai
mais ce travail est salutaire
aujourd'hui et que c'est la première
fois qu'on entend ces victimes j'espère
que elles oseront parler nous on a
travaillé sur andreu une 13 lama on
estime qu on a évidemment il ya beaucoup
plus de victimes qu'on n'a pas encore
entendu merci beaucoup vendre et il
avoue être venue nous parler de votre
enquête donc bouddhisme la loi du
silence un livre chez jean claude lattès
on le voit est un documentaire à revoir
encore jusqu'au mois de novembre je
crois sur arte on salue votre co
réalisatrice qui n'est pas là pour de
très bonnes raisons et on embrasse